>>Teacher: What have we got today?
>>Narrator: It's a big
day for these students
at Rockledge Elementary
in Bowie, Maryland.
It's the day they open
an envelope full
of paper monarch butterflies
made by students in Mexico.
>>Teacher: She lives in Mexico,
and she's given us her address,
and how many think they could
write a note back to her,
because wouldn't you like to know who
is going to get the ones you made?
>>Narrator: The arrival of these
symbolic butterflies mirrors the
annual migration of monarchs
from their winter home in Mexico
to North America each spring.
Following the migration is
just one part of Journey North,
a comprehensive set of project-based
learning activities delivered free
to schools across the
country via the Internet.
>>Teacher: Okay, let
me bring the map up.
What we're going to do is we're going
to follow the path of the monarchs.
>>Narrator: Exploring
the interrelated aspects
of seasonal change,
students follow the migration
of several different animals and
add their personal observations
to the global Journey North database.
>>Elizabeth: And I really appreciate
the incredible power of the Internet
as a communication tool, because you
can be speaking to kids up in Alaska
about the snowstorm that just hit
up there and the whales that are
on their way, and even a
kindergartener seeing their first
robin is of importance
to everybody else.
>>Teacher: Another state
where the monarchs are going
to be visiting; Kyle?
>>Kyle: West Virginia?
>>Narrator: Frances Koontz has
used Journey North in her classes
for the past seven years to touch
on everything from science, math,
and social studies to
ecology and English.
For Koontz, Journey North works.
>>Frances: Because it's authentic,
because we actually write letters,
for instance, the children
take an ownership of that.
Their writing is better.
Because they know somebody really
is going to read that letter,
they're much more careful
about their penmanship,
about their grammar, about spelling.
So I'm able to bring all of those
language-arts skills into an activity
that is real and authentic.
Social studies comes
in with the butterflies
because Journey North
people are just wonderful
about bringing us information
about the children in Mexico.
>>Teacher: [Speaking Spanish]
>>Child: The air temperature
is 63 degrees.
>>Narrator: Students get a
chance to act as scientists,
making observations of natural
phenomena right outside their
classroom door and sharing
their findings with their peers
and scientists around the globe.
>>Frances: The science is just
extremely rich, so really,
almost every part of my curriculum
can be brought into Journey North,
and Journey North can be
integrated in some way into it.
And it meets the state's standards,
which is, of course, my benchmark.
>>Go all the way down.
>>Narrator: Another Journey North
activity is a geographical game
called The Mystery Class.
Teams of students compete to
identify a secret spot on the globe
by deciphering scientific and
cultural clues to the locale.
>>Girl: We were trying to guess
where our mystery class was.
It could be anywhere in the world.
Now we think it's Malaysia in Kuala
Lumpur, the capital of Malaysia.
>>Boy: And the weird thing about
the photo period is each time,
it increases one or two minutes.
>>Girl: And that means
it's by the equator.
>>Frances: Then I can step back,
now that they have this knowledge,
and just let them interact with
each other and bring out a product.
It's just wonderful to watch.
>>Narrator: While Journey North
relies on sophisticated technology
to deliver information,
there is no substitute
for a first-hand experience
of nature's small miracles.
>>Frances: What does that tell us?
>>Monarchs are here.
>>Frances: It might be a monarch.
>>Frances: We were lucky enough to
have a patch of milkweed in the front
of the school, and we found 57 eggs
and larvae and brought them in.
We actually were able to watch one
of the butterflies
emerge from its chrysalis.
That's something they'll
never, never forget.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to Edutopia.org.